so geht's jetzt weiter bund und länder
sind sich einig die kontakt
beschränkungen bleiben bestehen kleinere
läden dürfen wieder öffnen schulen
schrittweise ein beutel hoffnung mit dem
blutplasma genesener kubik 19 patienten
wollen ärzte schwer erkrankten helfen
und stillstand nach der katastrophe ein
jahr nach dem verheerenden feuer in der
pariser notre dame liegt die baustelle
im dornröschenschlaf
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg ein mit spannung
erwarteter nachrichten tag schön dass
sie dabei sind guten abend deutschland
habe einen verbrechen zwischen erfolg im
kampf gegen das virus erreicht das sagt
die kanzlerin aber es sei weiter
äußerste vorsicht geboten
deswegen werden die kontakt
beschränkungen bis dritten mai
verlängert dazu wird dringend empfohlen
einfache gesichtsmasken zu tragen aber
es gibt auch lockerungen ab montag
dürfen läden unter 800 quadratmetern
verkaufsfläche wieder öffnen auch
autohäuser fahrrad und buchhändler ab
vierten mai auch friseure allerdings
alle nur unter strengen auflagen
schulen können schrittweise öffnen
zunächst nur für abschluss und prüfungs
klassen und großveranstaltungen bleiben
bis ende august verboten
klaus brodbeck hat mehr vier stunden
beratung danach steht fest wie das land
künftig mit dem virus leben soll
corona das wird klar ist noch lange
nicht besiegt das ist ein zwischenerfolg
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und ich
betone es ist ein zerbrechlicher
zwischenerfolg
die meisten maßnahmen werden bis dritten
mal verlängert zudem werden den bürgern
jetzt sogenannte alltags masken
empfohlen es gibt aber auch lockerungen
und das wirtschaftliche und soziale
leben wieder hochzufahren
friseure dürfen am vierten mai eröffnen
wenn sie ein hygiene konzept vorliegen
ebenso geschäfte bis zu 800 quadratmeter
und bibliotheken die sogar schon ab
nächster woche restaurants dürfen nur
langsam und unter strengen auflagen
wieder öffnen das abstandsgebot bleibt
das gilt weiterhin und die verstöße
dagegen werden auch weiter von den
ordnungsbehörden geahndet wir haben
keine unkontrollierten exit strategien
diskutiert sondern wir setzen weiter auf
vorsicht auf vorsicht denn wir glauben
dass die größte gefahr bestehen könnte
dass die guten zahlen das heißt guten
zahlen also die entwicklung die stabiles
dass die einen rückschlag erleidet wenn
wir zu viel riskieren wenn wir
leichtsinnig werden und wenn wir
normalität vortäuschen dies noch nicht
geben kann
gottesdienste und ähnliches bleiben
verboten der innenminister soll jedoch
mit den religionsgemeinschaften darüber
beraten
großveranstaltungen bleiben bis ende
august tabu die kritische nachricht ist
wir haben nicht viel spielraum
das eis ist dünn wir müssen bei allem
was wir tun
wir denken dass der erfolg der
bisherigen maßnahmen nicht in frage
gestellt wird
schulen dürfen ab vierten mal wieder
öffnen mit schwerpunkt auf
abschlussklassen hier aber sind
unterschiede von land zu land möglich
theo koll in berlin
welchen ausblick hat die kanzlerin
gegeben auf was müssen wir uns
einstellen
nun sie hat es wirklich mit einem
eindrucksvollen begriff benannt nämlich
diesen zerbrechlichen zwischen erfolg
und der hamburger erste bürgermeister
hat es eben anders formuliert das eis
dünn es ist ein eis das in teilen jetzt
schon tragen soll
aber es ist dünn und im grunde hat man
dazu aufgefordert weiterhin extrem
vorsichtig zu sein die maßnahmen sind
eine gewisse lockerung sie sind aber
natürlich eine sehr reduzierte
begrenzung beziehungsweise öffnung also
der einzelhandel nur ab einer bestimmten
unterhalb einer bestimmten größe also
unterhalb von 800 quadratmetern
verkaufsfläche so dass da nicht zu viele
menschen sein können im geschäft wir
sind aufgefordert masken zu tragen beim
einkauf und auch im öffentlichen
nahverkehr
weil man dort nicht immer die abstands
gebote einhalten kann
es ist keine pflicht aber so wurde
formuliert wir sind dringend geboten
künftig diese masken zu tragen ist das
jetzt das vieldiskutierte gemeinsame
vorgehen oder gebt dann jedes bundesland
auch seinen eigenen weg ich glaube die
unterschiede werden gering sein das hat
sich eben angedeutet beispielsweise bei
dem öffnen der einzelhandelsgeschäfte da
es kommt bayern vielleicht eine zeitlang
später eine woche später so hat es eben
der ministerpräsiden formuliert aber im
wesentlichen wenn man sich vergleicht
mit dem getöse im vorfeld wo jeder sein
unterschiedlichen positionen schon mal
formuliert hatte ist jetzt sehr viel
einigkeit erzielt also man hat im
wesentlichen auch bei den schulen und so
weiter sind ja die zeit maße eigentlich
sehr unterschiedlich vor den
sommerferien also auch die dringlichkeit
war unterschiedlich und trotzdem hat man
sich da weitgehend geeinigt ich höre es
gab ein auseinandersetzung zwischen dem
ministerpräsidenten über die größe der
eröffnenden geschäfte also da wollte
bayern beispielsweise nur eine
verkaufsfläche von 400 quadratmeter
andere wollten mehr
da hat man sich aber auch dann nach
langen diskussionen offensichtlich
geeinigt einschätzung von unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondent im theo koll
vielen dank
kritik kommt vom handelsverband der
moniert dass erstmal nur kleine läden
geöffnet werden dürfen gerade in
großflächigen betrieben sei es
wesentlich einfacher zum beispiel
abstands gebote einzuhalten
eines ist klar um all die
voraussetzungen zum wieder öffnen zu
erfüllen ist noch viel zu tun
sowohl in den schulen als auch im handel
aus rheinland pfalz und aus bayern
berichten julia schröter und petra
neubauer peter büscher sehnt den tag
herbei an dem er seinen alteingesessenen
lederwaren und koffer laden in münchen
endlich wieder aufsperren kann schon
jetzt bereitet er alles vor und macht
sich gedanken darüber wie er mögliche
vorgaben umsetzen kann
wahrscheinlich zwischen zwei drei leute
im laden darauf hinauslaufen dass werden
wir draußen kultur auch auf unserer
homepage bereit stellen und da muss man
auch vermutlich draußen so eine
abstandsregelung machen auch claudia
kemper steht in ihrem ballett laden in
den startlöchern
dass es jetzt wieder losgehen soll freut
sie zwar doch es drängen sich bei ihr
auch so viele fragen auf wie schaffen
wir den mindestabstand zu halten wenn er
gar nicht breiter ist sie 120 wie kann
man da 150 abstand halten
wie erklärt man das denn die leute die
sachen probieren wollen fast vier wochen
ist der buchladen von nicoletta miller
nun schon geschlossen die kosten aber
laufen weiter sie steht mit dem rücken
zur wand und ist bei weitem kein
einzelfall bilanziert der handelsverband
allein der bayerische einzelhandel
verliert jeden tag 185 millionen euro
das eine gewaltige summe und vielen
steht wirklich das wasser bis zum hals
lockerungen also ja bitte aber auch bei
den ladeninhabern ist sicherheit das
thema es muss halt auch garantiert sein
dass die kunden sowohl auch wir sicher
sind in dem rahmen unserer möglichkeiten
peter büscher jedenfalls hat auf eigene
rechnung schon mundschutzmasken besorgt
die er im bedarfsfall seinen kunden zur
verfügung stellen will keine schüler
keine lehrer die klassenräume im mainzer
gutenberg gymnasium sind verwaist doch
nicht mehr lange
ab dem 27 april sollen in rheinland
pfalz abiturienten und berufsschüler
wieder zur schule gehen
ab dem vierten mai dann schrittweise
weitere schüler folgen zuerst die oberen
klassen für schulleiter martin russ gibt
es jetzt viel zu organisieren
es geht zum einen natürlich um hand
desinfektion und ähnliches da müssen die
notwendigen spender und
desinfektionsmittel vorhanden sein und
zum anderen ist natürlich auch die frage
wie man die schülerinnen und schüler
sind mit masken ausstattet welche
qualität sollen und müssen diese massen
haben wie oft im laufe des vormittags
müssen sie gewechselt werden die
abstandsregeln ließen sich bei guter
planung einhalten sagte er
mit gruppen teilung eventuell einem
schichtsystem auch in grundschulen
sollen die abschlussklassen als erstes
wieder an den start den älteren wird
noch am ehesten zugetraut hygiene
abstandsregeln zu beherzigen
bei den kleineren ist das schwieriger
die kinder sind sehr impulsiv es braucht
einen kleinen anlass und alle hängen
dann doch wieder zusammen
da muss man schon genau aufpassen
unabhängig von der schulart
elternvertreter halten den neustart des
unterrichts anfang mai für zu ehrgeizig
im moment sehen wir als bundeselternrat
leider nicht dass die hygienemaßnahmen
eingehalten werden können dass dort hin
dass das besagen umgesetzt worden ist
darf haben die letzten wochen zu viel
zeit versäumt der unterricht soll wieder
anlaufen dafür werden jetzt pläne
erarbeitet
ein schulbus konzept muss her und auch 1
für die pausen an dieser stelle schnell
eine korrektur restaurants lokale und
bars
anders als vorhin erwähnt vorerst nicht
geöffnet in diesem bereich gibt es keine
lockerungen der zeit was uns noch
bevorsteht das langsamer öffnen von
schulen das hat in dänemark heute schon
begonnen zum ersten mal gingen kinder
dort wieder in den kindergarten und zur
grundschule allerdings unter erheblichen
auflagen wie heike kruse zeit fähnchen
schwenkende strahlende lehrer warten auf
ihre schüler auch an der kopenhagener
büro schule ein seltener anblick mehr
als vier wochen waren alle dänischen
schulen und kitas geschlossen wird seit
heute sind sie bis zur fünften klasse
geöffnet viele eltern sorgen sich aber
um die gesundheit ihrer kinder
ich war schon skeptisch als ich das
hörte was die regierung machen will
aber als ich die maßnahmen hier an der
schule sagt war ich beruhigt die
organisieren das ja auch richtig gut und
so sehen sie nun überall aus die
strengen regeln hände desinfizieren alle
zwei stunden händewaschen kein essen
miteinander teilen
zwei meter abstand im klassenzimmer
zueinander
gerade für jüngere kinder nicht einfach
für die regierung ein notwendiger erster
schritt zurück zur normalität
wir müssen eine ausgewogene lösung
finden zwischen der gesundheit auf der
einen und besseren arbeits und
lebensbedingungen für jeden auf der
anderen seite das haben wir bisher
gemacht und das werden wir weitermachen
kleine schulen fehlen oft noch räume um
die abstandsregeln einzuhalten viele
pädagogen sehen die nächsten unterrichts
wochen als experiment gefragtes krise
service erst noch zeigen was das alles
mit den schülern macht immer auf abstand
ist es etwa gut für die disziplin oder
vereinsamen
die erste große pause an der
gesamtschule nova büro zeigt deutlich
wie schwierig das ist normalität mit
abstand wir schauen noch mal nach
deutschland denn auch heute gibt es
aktuelle corona zahlen stand 8 10 uhr 30
sind bei uns laut johns hopkins
universität 132 1718 infektionen durch
tests bestätigt als genesen geltend
72.600 menschen 3592 starben in
verbindung
dem virus die zahlen steigen also weiter
aber langsamer
anfang märz hatte sich die zahl der
erkrankten noch alle zwei tage
verdoppelt nun sind es knapp 33 tage
us-präsident jump hat seine drohung
wahrgemacht mitten in der korona krise
stoppt er die beitragszahlungen an die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die whu seit
zu china freundlich und habe in der
korona krise nichts um genug gefahren
die usa sind mit rund 400 millionen
dollar jährlich der größte
beitragszahler un-generalsekretär
ätherisch verurteilte den zahlungsstopp
die whu sei absolut entscheidend im
kampf gegen die epidemie auch die
bundesregierung kritisierte die
entscheidung zurück nach deutschland
eine massen unterkunft für flüchtlinge
in ellwangen in baden württemberg gibt
rätsel auf vergangene woche gab es dort
einige wenige corona fälle jetzt sind
rund die hälfte der 500 bewohner
infiziert die behörden haben dafür keine
erklärung und beteuern alle
sicherheitsregeln sein befolgt worden
anna basbug rund um die uhr wird die
landes erstaufnahmestelle jetzt bewacht
die polizei kontrolliert die strikte
ausgangssperre von außen
drinnen infizieren sich die flüchtlinge
in rasantem tempo
vor zwei wochen war es noch ein
einzelner corona fall jetzt sind es 259
wir hatten keine bewohner oder nur einen
bewohner mit verdacht symptomen mit
krankheitssymptomen den haben wir
natürlich sofort separiert auch seine
kontaktpersonen haben wir separiert die
infizierung hat wohl unbemerkt
stattgefunden in einer massen unterkunft
mit gemeinschaftsduschen und großkantine
keimzelle für ein virus und in der
jetzigen corona krise um zumutbar für
die bewohner kritisieren organisationen
wie der flüchtlingsrat baden württemberg
man hätte die leute schon vor wochen da
rausholen sollen weil es klar ist dass
es da eben
unvermeidbar ist da das infektionsrisiko
entstehen und konkret war von unserer
seite aus der vorschlag dass man dafür
beispielsweise leerstehende hotels
jugendherbergen und sonstiges nutzt
stattdessen steht die komplette
einrichtung unter quarantäne
keiner der infizierten müsste bisher zur
behandlung ins krankenhaus sagen die
zuständigen behörden mehr als 20
beschäftigte sind mittlerweile auch
infiziert und die korona tests laufen
weiter um schwer erkrankten corona
patienten zu helfen setzen ärzte in
mehreren kliniken mittlerweile auf
blutplasma bereits genesen menschen
denn nach einer corona infektion bildet
der körper abwehrkräfte gegen den
erreger
das wollen die forscher nutzen aus dem
blut genesene wird das blutplasma
gewonnen der teil in dem die antikörper
stecken das wird dann aufbereitet und
kranken verabreicht um deren
abwehrkräfte zu stärken
patricia schäfer hat details
in diesem beutel ruht die hoffnung auf
heilung es ist blutplasma dass ein
ehemaliger corona infizierter spendet er
hat die krankheit bereits hinter sich
und damit ein wertvolles körpereigenes
mittel gegen das virus antikörper wirken
werden von den antikörper die diese
patienten gebildet haben direkt
attackiert und vernichtet deswegen ist
das die einzige akteur mögliche
spezifische nico spezifische therapie
die wir in der hand haben
seit zehn tagen arbeiten die mediziner
der regensburger uniklinik mit diesen
plasmaspenden hunderte genesene haben
sich gemeldet täglich werden bis zu fünf
spenden abgenommen
in der mikrobiologie werden die proben
mit einem hier vor ort eigens für tobit
19 entwickelten antikörper test geprüft
ich bin da sehr optimistisch wir haben
schon spender gefunden die gute mengen
neutralisierende antikörper im blut
haben und diese wurden bereits auch an
die ersten patienten hier bei uns in
regensburg übertragen mehr als 40
patienten wurden seit voriger woche mit
dem antikörper klasse behandelt schwere
und mittelschwere fälle
nebenwirkungen wurden in regensburg
bisher nicht beobachtet aber erste
erfolge verzeichnet die infektions
parameter also die anzeichen der
infektion verbessern sich nach einigen
tagen das für die teen zur parameter der
dann doch relativ zügig feld und wenn
die patienten noch eine viruslast haben
also wie ein in sich haben
da ziehen wir durchaus dass die virus
last abnimmt bzw
bei einem patienten ist völlig
verschwunden so können ehemalige corona
patienten denen helfen die im moment mit
der krankheit kämpfen und möglicherweise
leben retten
zur kuba krise sehen sie heute auch ein
zdf spezial exit strategie für
deutschland direkt im anschluss an
unsere nachrichten fahnder in nordrhein
westfalen haben offenbar eine
terrorzelle ausgehoben vier männer
wurden festgenommen sie sollen sich zum
islamischen staat bekennen und aus
tadschikistan stammen laut
bundesanwaltschaft haben sich die männer
waffen besorgt und anschläge auf us
einrichtungen in deutschland geplant
felix zimmermann
am nachmittag werden die mutmaßlichen
terroristen dem haftrichter beim
bundesgerichtshof vorgeführt
vorangegangen waren durchsuchungen und
festnahmen durch die bundesanwaltschaft
in 13 objekten in nordrhein westfalen
insgesamt fünf männer sollen anschläge
auf us amerikanische militär basen in
deutschland geplant haben und auch den
mord an einem islamkritischen youtuber
die gruppe soll aus dem ausland
gesteuert worden seien
sie standen im engen kontakt mit zwei
hochrangigen heeres führungsspielern in
syrien und in afghanistan und von diesen
erhielten die beschuldigten dass es
soweit erwiesen entsprechende
anweisungen alle fünf beschuldigten sind
als flüchtlinge aus tadschikistan
gekommen
das regime dort unterdrückt die
opposition und die freie
religionsausübung ein nährboden für
terrorismus viele taktiken haben sich
at&s kämpfer anwerben lassen
die meisten von denen sind nach syrien
und irak gegangen und ich den
islamischen staates angeschlossen
dort war in der dicke sogar eine
zeitlang so genannter kriegsminister und
der hatte einen ziemlich großen anfangen
und es kann schon sein dass flüchtlinge
gastarbeiter in anderen ländern dann
auch online rekrutiert werden wenn
syrien und dem irak hat die von den usa
geführte koalition den es weitestgehend
besiegt doch die verhaftung heute zeigen
erneut die terrorgefahr für
amerikanische und europäische ziele
besteht weiter nach paris es war genau
heute gleiche uhrzeit vor einem jahr als
notre dame in flammen stand eine der
berühmtesten kathedralen der welt denn
dachstuhl aus jahrhunderte altem holz
brennt völlig aus ein turm in der mitte
stürzt ein
in fünf jahren werde das wahrzeichen von
paris wieder aufgebaut sein dass
versprach präsident makro damals und
auch heute wieder
trotz corona aus paris christel hass
nur die große glocke emanuel im südturm
wird am abend läuten einsames gedenken
in corona zeiten auch die bauarbeiten
sind wegen der pandemie eingestellt noch
immer klafft ein riesiges loch im dach
des kirchenschiffs drumherum die trümmer
eines gerüsts das in der feuersbrunst
geschmolzen ist und nun stück für stück
abgetragen werden muss das ist wie ein
mikado spiel es könnten dabei teile auf
die gewölbe fallen auch wenn wir die
verstärkt haben
genau dort oben unter dem dach war das
feuer ausgebrochen das hölzerne gebellt
brannte wie zunder
dann stürzt der markante spitz turm in
die tiefe
kilometerlang die rauchwolke
auch die beiden haupt türme sind bedroht
nach 16 stunden erst ist das feuer
gelöscht
die schäden sind immens aber vieles ist
wider erwarten erhalten geblieben auch
wenn alle arbeiten an otto adam jetzt
gestoppt sind der präsident hält an
seinem 5 jahresziel fest
si noch ist die restaurierung von notre
dame ist für uns alle wichtig sie ist
ein symbol für die widerstandskraft
unseres volkes für die fähigkeit
herausforderungen zu meistern
noch ist die kathedrale nicht gänzlich
stabilisiert jeder einzelne stein muss
auf seine standfestigkeit geprüft werden
mit dem wiederaufbau der zerstörten
teile kann wohl erst mitte nächsten
jahres begonnen werden
so lange werden die brandwunden von
notre dame weiter sichtbar seien zu
empfehlen dazu ist unsere zdf heute app
die liefert ein interaktives 3d modell
der kathedrale da können sie genau sehen
wie sich der brand entwickelt hat und
wie der wiederaufbau funktionieren soll
und jetzt noch wie immer mittwochs die
lottozahlen
sie lauten 11 22 24 27 30 46 und die
superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
das wetter bleibt schön und es wird noch
wärmer zu den aussichten gleich gut
um 22 uhr freut sich marietta slomka ob
sie im heute journal
morgen übernimmt hier petra gerster
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem zdf spezial
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer für die meisten von
ihnen würde es morgen deutlich wärmer
werden und nachts wird auch nicht mehr
so kalt nur vereinzelt gibt es noch mal
frost bis minus 1 oder 0 grad sonst zwei
bis sieben grad klaren himmel haben wir
und morgen scheint dann erstmal überall
die sonne aber über den nordosten ziehen
dann doch ein paar dichtere wolkenfelder
und an der ostsee haben ja nur anfangs
noch einen starken nordwestwind der
lässt dann auch wieder nach aber es ist
frisch dort im norden also sind meist 12
bis 17 grad sonst in der mitte und im
süden 18 bis 25 grad ja warum geht es
auch mal ist weiter nur an den küsten
bleibt es kühl und zum wochenende gibt
es im süden immer wieder schauer und
gewitter ich wünschen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut